bienvenue dans le débat politique y
aura-t-il des élèves à l'école un peu
plus de 10 jours de la rentrée poste
confinement c'est une des conditions de
la reprise du travail pour certains
parents d'où notre question en débat ce
soir de la maternelle à la 5e l'école
vatel faire office de garderie au delà
de sa mission d'instruction pour en
débattre nous sommes avec lydia guirous
ce essayiste et ancien porte-parole les
républicains et face à vous patrick
mennucci ancien député du parti
socialiste et conseiller municipal à
marseille
bonsoir à tous les deux ravis de vous
retrouver merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france on va d'abord écouté le premier
ministre qui a précisé mardi à
l'assemblée nationale les principes de
la reprise scolaire et on en parle juste
après commençons par l'école le
président de la république l'a rappelé
le retour de nos enfants sur le chemin
des écoles est un impératif pédagogique
un impératif de justice sociale en
particulier pour ceux qui peuvent dit si
difficilement suivre l'enseignement à
distance
ce retour nous voulons le concilier avec
la préservation de nos objectifs de
santé publique
pour ce faire nous proposons une
réouverture très progressive des
maternelle et de l'école élémentaire à
compter du 11 mai partout sur le
territoire et sur la base du volontariat
voilà donc ramené en quelque sorte les
décrocheurs à l'école sur la base du
volontariat de façon très prudente
le premier ministre a exposé les
modalités de son déconfinement pour les
maternelles notamment lydia guirous ce
qu'ont pensé vous est ce qu'on va
pouvoir amener les décrocheurs à l'école
sur la base du volontariat
alors malheureusement jeu ça part d'une
bonne intention mais ramener les
décrocheurs à l'école sur la base du
volontariat ça vous semble assez
difficile
je pense que malheureusement ils n'ont
pas les parents qui ont envie de les
pousser vers le vers le chemin de
l'école et je ne crois pas que cela va
permettre d'autant plus qu'il ya
beaucoup de municipalités qui ont
indiqué qu'ils
réouvrirait pas les écoles le 11 mai je
pense au maire de montreuil qui a déjà
déclaré qu'il ne pouvait pas les 54
établissements de sa commune et beaucoup
d'autres parce que ils considèrent que
c'est très compliqué avec un document
qui a été diffusée par l'éducation
nationale qui étaient 63 pages la
responsabilité renvoyés vers les locaux
et notamment les mères c'est c'est très
difficile dans les déclarations du
premier ministre il y avait beaucoup de
en même temps au final le volontariat
pour l'école je trouve que c'est
compliqué à mettre en place
l'école doit être obligatoire pour tous
et tous nous faisons tous rentrer
retourner à l'école le plus rapidement
possible en respectant évidemment les
conditions de sécurité sanitaire pour
pour garantir un retour à l'école
sécurisé pour nos enfants à l'école ou
obligatoire ou volontaire patrick
mennucci qu'en pensez vous est-ce que
c'est simplement une façon finalement
garder les enfants
les professeurs vont faire office de
nous je crois que la question que vous
posez sur la garderie je crois que tous
les français ont compris il s'agit de
permettre de reprendre une activité
économique et de garder leurs enfants
je ne vois pas très bien aujourd'hui je
ne comprends pas j'ai discuté avec
plusieurs maires de grandes et de
petites villes et il y a une volonté
chez eux
khiter qui est de servir ils ne sont pas
là pour mettre des bâtons dans les roues
quelle que soit leur orientation
politique simplement pour eux comme pour
nous d'ailleurs
c'est la question sanitaire qui est
d'abord celle qui prévaut donc il
examine les conditions dans lesquelles
ils peuvent permettre à des enfants de
se tenir ensemble dans une école est
d'être dans des conditions sanitaires
normal je pense notamment à la
déclaration de martine aubry qui dit que
dans
les classes de lille elle pourra
difficilement avoir plus de 10 en forme
pour respecter un cadre
donc voilà je crois que nous sommes dans
un grand flou ce gouvernement a montré
beaucoup d'amateurisme depuis 2010 est
évidemment l'amateurisme est toujours un
problème mais il est autant plus
cantonné dans une situation aussi grave
que de celle dans laquelle on se
retrouve dès qu'il ya un grand flou
pourtant il y a effectivement tout un
protocole sanitaire qui a été rendu
public aujourd'hui avec des mesures très
précises pour que ce ce déconfinement
pour les petits se passe bien
y at il encore des raisons finalement de
refuser à ce que les enfants et à
l'école ni d'alliance et écouter ses
c'est très difficile le document met
beaucoup de conditions et pensez vous
que des enfants en maternelle pourront
respecter la distanciation sociale je ne
crois pas passer moi accueillir 15
élèves par classe il me semble pour pour
la primaire c'est ses traits c'est très
difficile à mettre en place il faut que
les classes soient suffisamment grand
des sceaux que les bureaux soient
espacés il ya le problème également de
la cantine donc je le port du masque il
va être très difficile à mettre en place
également pour offre ces enfants là donc
tout ça est très difficile et en même
temps je suis très inquiète parce que
tant que nous n'aurons pas un vaccin à
quel moment les enfants retourneront
tous à l'ecal à quel moment nous
retournerons tous à travailler
enfin la dre pas avant deux ans lydia
guirous ça il est indispensable aussi
que nous retournions travailler parce
que l'économie doit fonctionner et s'il
ya une crise économique qui s'avère
aussi importante que ce qu'on nous
prédit ça va être de nos gros drames
sociaux qui vont générer aussi des
drames et des problèmes sanitaires très
très important donc là pour le moment
c'est extrêmement je trouve que c'est
très difficile de faire respecter tout
toutes ces conditions qui sont qui sont
demandés que ce soit la maternelle au
primaire pour pour les enfants je ne
vois pas très bien comment un enfant
peut rester
le tort du mas la distanciation sociale
le fait que des dictées que les enfants
se croisent jouent ensemble ça va même
jusqu'à les jeux de ballons qui vont
être interdits ça va être extrêmement
difficile humainement il ne reste que
deux mois est ce que ça vaut la peine
patrick mennucci de faire entrer ses
enfants à l'école sauf impératif
économique évidemment je crois que quand
le premier ministre parle des
décrocheurs il parlait des familles qui
sont il ya aussi les familles qui ne
sont pas en capacité de donner les cours
zone farman je fais depuis deux mois un
cours de deux de ces oeufs et gilles
j'avoue d'ailleurs il prendre beaucoup
de plaisir avec mon fils et je crois pas
qu'il perde son temps je crois que ce
que la maîtresse en bois tous les jours
nous le faisons et qui lui manque c'est
le contact avec ses amis
c'est le cadre social de l'école
évidemment pour les familles où les
parents n'ont pas cette capacité là à le
faire le retour à l'école et était
impératif simplement le problème c'est
que comme toujours avec ce gouvernement
tout ce qui est difficile dans des
confinement est renvoyé à la
responsabilité des maires qui ont été
très mal traités je vous le rappelle au
début du quinquennat qui aujourd'hui on
a besoin d'eux alors on revient vers eux
mais j'ai essayé de comprendre avec un
certain nombre de mes amis
attiches peut téléphoner pour savoir
pourquoi il hésite et beaucoup à ouvrir
les écoles
la question c'est ce qu'a dit lidia il
ya la question sanitaire
mais il ya aussi les questions
techniques il y à de nombreux agents
municipaux qui sont présents dans les
écoles ou dans les maternelles qui
sont aujourd'hui pour beaucoup certaines
est en tout cas un arrêt maladie
il y a une difficulté pour recruter il
faut certainement pour permettre que les
gestes barrière en soit fait par les
enfants
ce que décrivent et lydia et nesta il
faut plus de personnel que le personnel
habituel et donc il faut recruter
donc il ya aussi des problèmes
financiers des problèmes de formation
les choses ne sont pas simples et on
voit que des grandes collectivités
je pense notamment à la collectivité à
la communauté d'agglomération de lens
liévin dans le bassin minier
l'unanimité des 34 mère qui sombre dans
cette collectivité présidée par sylvain
robert le maire de las viennent de
décider de ne pas ouvrir les écoles oui
et c'est le cas même si la pluie borgia
parler de montreuil aux mêmes droits que
je peux vous dire a par exemple commencé
rien n'est très bien les écoles que dont
nous avons parlé et qui sommes très
dégradé le sont toujours autant
aujourd'hui
moi j'ai jamais vu mon savon dans les
écoles marseillais alors il va falloir
évidemment évidemment et vous parlez des
conditions déplorables de certaines
écoles qui sont dénoncées depuis de
nombreuses années on va en parler on va
écouter frédéric bierry le président du
conseil départemental du bas-rhin lui
aussi a appelé les parents à ne pas
remettre leurs enfants à l'école écoutez
le j'invite les parents à ne pas
scolariser leurs enfants avant le 25 mai
j'ai eu l'occasion d'aller dans une
maison d'enfants à caractère social où
il y avait beaucoup d'enfants pour leur
apporter des tablettes
j'ai bien vu les gestes de protection la
distanciation sociale c'est très
compliqué pour les enfants donc le
risque de relancer la pandémie est
important et nous on peut faire des
grandes théories mais dans la vraie vie
des enfants c'est plus complexe
lydia games on voit il ya un décalage
entre le principe la feuille de route le
plan de déconfinement et les modalités
sanitaires et effectivement ce qui se
vit
sur le terrain néanmoins là on le voit
c'est les maires qui font quasiment
l'unanimité contre le gouvernement oui
effectivement les merdes
il ya cette question de la mise en
pratique de ce qui est recommandé par le
ministère de l'éducation nationale et
qui est extrêmement difficile d'autant
plus que comme le rappelait patrick
mennucci c'est ce gouvernement qui a
supprimé des postes notamment des
assistants de vie dans dans les écoles
qui est des dents dans les petites
classes dans maternelle et il ya la
question de la responsabilité pénale
pour ces élus et c'est vrai que le
gouvernement a tendance à oublier voire
à mépriser les élus locaux
quand quand ils le souhaitent et lorsque
léa situation est plus difficile et plus
complexe avec la question de la
responsabilité et voir la gagne cette
peur des procès qu'il ya une très grande
judiciarisation maintenant en france
avec 2,2 dans de nombreuses plaintes et
bien là il retrouve les élus locaux qui
se protège et je trouve que c'est c'est
vraiment dommage pour ces enfants parce
qu'il ya une vraie rupture dans leur
dans leur apprentissage alors quand ils
ont la chance d'avoir des parents qui
peuvent les accompagner et les aider
c'est très bien ça crée des moments
privilégiés avec les parents qu'il faut
pouvoir quand même en même temps faire
son travail être en télétravail et gérer
les devoirs des enfants et c'est une
charge très lourd mais pour ceux qui
n'ont pas cette possibilité là ça va
creuser encore plus les inégalités et
rappelons qu' aussi la question de
l'alimentation où il ya des familles qui
ne parviennent pas à alimenter leurs
enfants correctement et la cantine
c'était c'était un moment où les enfants
peuvent avoir un plat et un repas
équilibré dans la journée et en ce
moment depuis le confinement saint moka
ces enfants là donc je pense que ça
c'est aussi une des motivations du
gouvernement mais j'aimerais qu'ils
aient enfin le courage de décider qu'on
retourne à l'école tous ou alors on ne
retourne pas l'école mais on ne le fait
pas sur la base du volontariat en
renvoyant la responsabilité aux élus
kib locaux qui vont avoir à la plus
grande difficulté du monde a tranché et
a poussé
les familles à ramener les enfants à
l'école d'autant plus que ce que je ne
comprends pas c'est qu'au début on vous
a expliqué que les enfants étaient les
plus contagieux il fallait presque les
laisser à la réole ce n'est plus le cas
selon les experts maintenant ce n'est
plus le cas donc si ce n'est plus le cas
on peut considérer qu'on peut emmener
ses enfants à l'école sans danger va
falloir que les experts scientifiques se
mettent d'accord sont ils les plus
dangereux contagieux ou ne le sentais
pas il ya un moment il faut ils sont
qu'on puisse aussi alors résonner sur
sur la base d'expertisés qui s'arrête
parce que parce qu'on ne sait pas
véritablement où on va et tant qu'on
n'aura pas de vaccin est-ce qu'en
septembre sont pas encore dans les mêmes
débats jean ne pourra pas de
déscolariser comme ça éternellement les
élèves et on ne pourra pas avoir des
écoles qui vont accueillir uniquement 10
ou 15 élèves par classe c'est ça va être
extrêmement difficile donc d'ici
septembre viendra quand même trouver une
solution parce que malheureusement je ne
pense pas qu'en septembre nous aurons un
vaccin
lydia guirous ce l'est républicain avait
devancé le plan de déconfinement du
premier ministre en proposant en
proposant des mesures et pour les cognes
préconisait plutôt de remettre à l'école
et les plus âgés les collèges les lycées
en priorité avant les petits ça vous
semblez plus raisonnable c'était plus
raisonnable dans la mesure où les plus
grands peuvent mieux respecter les
gestes de distanciation social est porté
et porter le masque donc c'était
peut-être plus facile à mettre en oeuvre
mais pour pouvoir retourner au travail
les familles qui ont des enfants
beaucoup plus jeunes ont besoin de les
faire de les faire garder les enfants
d'une volée j'ai regardé tout seul et
c'est important que que l'on se remette
au travail et pour redresser notre
économie parce que derrière la crise
économique ça va être des drames sociaux
et d aider des drames de la santé la la
crise de 2008 certains médecins nous ont
indiqué que ça a généré 50 mille cas de
cancer et énormément d'autres maladies
térieur s'est ravi jean paul minn
patrick mennucci pardon c'est votre avis
il faut remettre à tout prix les
personnes au travail et donc les enfants
à l'école kita à servir de garde
que je pense que le pays a intérêt à
redémare économiquement et donc que les
enfants aillent à l'école
mais avant cela il faut s'assurer de la
situation sanitaire
donc mon jeu je suis critique à la fois
de l'action du gouvernement depuis bien
longtemps
en même temps je mesure toute la
difficulté et je crois que le
gouvernement est en train aujourd'hui un
problème qui est que les français ne le
crois pas et ne le crois pas sur
l'histoire des masques il ne le crois
pas sur les questions de de détection de
test et donc ça pose un problème sur la
totalité des autres décisions que prend
l'état voilà lui mais ceci dit on n'aura
pas le général de gaulle à la tête de la
france pour effectivement comme m une
situation aussi difficile c'est sûr il
faut qu'on fasse ex que nous avons
malheureusement et je crois que ce qui
est important c'est que les maires de ce
pays redevienne des vrais interlocuteurs
qu'on les écoute on a l'impression que
c'est le cas aujourd'hui
gg je re je retiens mon sur martin weale
si je l' ai entendu lui hier et j'avais
l'impression que c'était le maire de
lille qui donnait des consignes aenor
philippe je trouvais ça plutôt
d'ailleurs intéressant parce que c'est
une femme d'expérience mais ça montre la
difficulté qu un gouvernement à se faire
encore membre et surtout parce que les
mesures qu'il propose ne sont pas data
pts adaptable partout où nous sommes je
le président du conseil départemental du
bas-rhin par
où il ya eu des centaines de décès il a
certainement pas la même position que le
président du conseil département de
parler de vous parler de confiance des
français patrick mennucci confiance des
français les deux parents ne voudront
pas amener leurs enfants à l'école on a
vu aussi les un certain flou artistique
entre les annonces de de jean michel
blanquer
le ministre de l'éducation nationale et
est ce qu a annoncé edouard philippe
le timing ne correspond pas ce flou
finalement est ce que c'est ça qui iront
ce gouvernement pas crédible nul à
guillaume est très méfiant mais c'est le
flou artistique
sakho définir un peu ce gouvernement on
nous a dit qu'il ne fallait pas porter
de masque les max ne servait à rien la
porte parole du gouvernement a fait une
démonstration pour dire qu'elle même ne
savait pas comment on portait un masque
en fait ils géraient simplement la
pénurie leur manque d'anticipation ans
dans cette crise la chine était confiné
depuis plusieurs mois il y avait des
signaux depuis plusieurs mois que la
pandémie pouvait se répondre également
en france ils ont longtemps considéré
qu' on avait une frontière qui faisait
que le virus n'avait pas arriver un peu
comme à tchernobyl à l'époque avec avec
avec le nuage en était à protéger et
ayez beaucoup de contradictions il ya eu
un manque de clarté il ya eu des indes
un manque de courage politique aussi
pour prendre des décisions et tout ça on
put la confiance que pouvaient avoir les
français en ce gouvernement et je pense
qu emmanuel macron aujourd'hui n'est pas
entouré des meilleurs pour voir clair
face c'est alors je voudrais qu'on ait
coude à ce propos justement une
déclaration de six bêtes ndiaye c'était
le 25 mars je vous demanderai une courte
réaction patrick mennucci il va sans
dire que nous n'entendons pas demander à
un enseignant qui aujourd'hui ne
travaille pas
compte tenu de la fermeture des écoles
de traverser la france entière pour
aller récolter des fraises gariguettes à
une déclaration qui a fait beaucoup de
mal aux 6,1 et qui a fait beaucoup
réagir les enseignants patrick mennucci
veut dire d'autre les déclarations de ce
type fait par la personne qui vous
attend est chargé de porter la bonne
parole
c'est totalement choquant là dedans
plusieurs éléments si son nom ridicule
le fait que des enseignants la réforme
je veux vous dire que la maîtresse de
mon fils l'on doit tous les soirs à
faire emplois dans ma famille à mon
épouse et moi tous les soirs les les
leçons du lendemain que les corrige que
nous avons fait ces derniers jours des
terres que les dettes sont revenues
corriger et celle d'avant le le fait ça
et les injures vital à remercier
chaleureusement
parce que l'école publique on s'aperçoit
cadre du travail des instituteurs qui en
soi même on est amené à éduquer nos pas
et verra prendre aux enfants
les pouvoirs c'est affligeant de voir la
porte-parole du gouverneur dire que les
deux aînés on ne travaille pas et merci
beaucoup
les gariguettes pour faire comme si tout
cela n'avait aucune importance mais elle
n'est pas à sa seule déclaration absurde
mais ça on a pris les rênes heureusement
merci patrick mennucci merci désolé de
de vous interrompre c'est la fin de ce
débat merci beaucoup lydia guirous ce et
patrick mennucci d'avoir participé à ce
débat politique par écran interposé
confinement oblige
merci à vous de votre fidélité rester
avec nous sur arte france